I heard you say or maybe it was your
executive producer and an interview say
we will believe it when we have a call
sheet yeah every time we're so yes it's
been what 6 to 16 years I mean so my
friend D Robertson and I we are the we
that puppets short film I made in
college that I wrote and he directed and
then we both went out to LA 2002 I think
he'd moved out a little earlier than me
but that's when we hatched the idea of
like let's do a feature like a puppet
human buddy cop movie and write it do it
as a feature we came up with the
characters together in the story and
then I wrote the script and the original
plan was like he was gonna direct it
we're gonna go out and make it ourselves
we're gonna raise a little bit of money
and go shoot it and then we realized oh
that's it's very expensive like to make
a puppet movie you have to build every
set because you need puppeteers under
the floorboards
so our thought of doing it is like a
cheap little indie like quit quickly
went away and we tried to set it up at a
couple places over the years but didn't
really pan out and so we put it on the
shelf and and for years people would get
interested in it and Dee and I would
always say Dee who's still heavily
involved with the movie isn't executive
producer in the movie we'd always be
like will believe it when we see a call
shade like they would attach an actor
and everyone would get excited if we
were like yeah well believe when we see
a call sheet or they get a bunch of
money like they'd set it up at a
financing company or a production
company we'd be like yeah we'll believe
it when we see a call sheet just because
year I mean we set it up at the Henson
Company in 2007 and years I mean nine
years went by with a lot of a lot of
times where it would look good but then
that happen and our joke deionised joke
with each other was always will believe
when we see a call sheet and then one
day I get a call that Melissa McCarthy's
doing the movie and they're gonna shoot
it and I was like yeah I'll believe it
when I see a call she like still still
and then one day I got a call she like
then one day I got an email with a PDF
in it
happy two murders shooting day one and I
was like oh it's real like it's really
real it's not gonna fall apart like it's
really happening and I went to set and I
got to see these puppet characters Dee
and I had came up with probably drunk at
a bar in 2002 and these locations like
that we had you know imagined years ago
we're like oh they built the set and
they built all these puppets and here
they are and they're actually shooting
this movie it's real and we're on set
here we are but still I was still
skeptical
I still like know something Bad's gonna
happen right like a meteors gonna hit
the soundstage still something Bad's
gonna happen like it's still part of me
sitting here with you right now the
movies gonna come out in a couple of
weeks I still think something horrible
is gonna happen like part of me my
pessimist personality is like
something's still horrible is gonna
happen right but I've seen billboards
and bus ads I've seen commercials this
movie's really happening it's really
coming out unless this is awesome
elaborate prank that you guys have all
been pulling on me which I would not be
surprised it could be a filk a dick
reality distortion we don't know is it
real am I really a puppet you know I
don't know I was not gonna be surprised
if I wake up tomorrow and I walk out
into my living room and I see my wife
and I'm like oh yeah the happy time
murders interview I did yesterday went
really well and my wife's like what's
the happy time murders I'm like wait
what and then I go to my computer and it
never has existed it's all been a dream
well if you're like most people myself
included I get nervous when things are
kind of going there because if you've
had the bottom fall out of certain
things this is a bad sign like I'm
always not just with like making movies
but with anything like if I get a new
router for my Wi-Fi and I plug it in and
it works right away I'm like what's
wrong right this is there's no way like
there's no way there was this easy
nothing's ever this easy it's going
straight to the White House exactly yes
didn't you write the script in like an
interesting scenario you went to a motel
we have so indeedy and I first came up
with the the characters like we slowly
came up with the characters and kind of
the loose outline of the plot and then
when I wrote the script when I was like
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to write
the script and then like Dee you're
gonna be kind of like my bounce board
you're gonna be in the room with me and
I'm gonna be able to like run stuff by
you so what we did was write we're gonna
get a hotel room and I'm gonna sit at
the laptop and you're gonna just like be
in the room like pacing or doing
whatever it is you're doing and in
helping me and so we went on online and
we just found the cheapest hotel room we
could possibly find which is by LAX and
it was like a quality inn
and it was like $39 and remember the
only food we have this grand vision of
being bohemian artist so we're gonna be
right in the hotel and then you show up
and it's just the saddest LAX hotel and
the only food anywhere near there was
there was an ampm where we could go get
coffee and there was a subway like a
24-hour subway that we would go eat at
but we holed up in this hotel for I
think it was one night and then we sat
in the lobby like we had to check out at
a certain time simply sat in the lobby
of the hotel across the street and we
just banged out like I begged out a
first draft I mean it wasn't good but I
mean it was Syria it was like 75 pages
in 24 hours or something like that just
writing just writing just writing and it
was pretty awesome
Deana we should go back to that hotel
just like the night of the premiere yeah
you should do an after-party in that sad
little LAX hotel room what were there
moments there that you're like what are
we doing this is this is like we're
almost living out a write or sort of
fantasy out of an 80s movie yeah I mean
as a writer you always have this vision
of like what writers are supposed to do
and so and I've even done that sense
like I've my jam now as I'd love to get
a hotel if I have to
I'm a dead lion I'll get a hotel room
for day they were for a night and I'll
just stay up all night writing or I was
read a novel a few years ago and when I
did the second draft of it I got a room
in Palm Springs for like a week and I
just went out there for a week and a
couple times I've had I've been on
deadline for a script like on an
assignment and I'm like oh I was
supposed to write the script over the
last eight weeks and I haven't started
it yet so I'm just gonna go get a hotel
room for a week but I did have a grand
vision of like oh you're supposed to
drink while writing right like isn't
that what her stimming way did so I did
buy like a big bottle of whiskey and put
it on the table and I'm like okay here
we go I'm gonna start writing and then I
would have a drink and one drink and I'm
like I don't want to write anymore I
want to just sit on that big comfortable
bed and watch a movie so I can't do that
I think some people can like drink
whiskey while they write because that's
what writers are supposed to do right I
can't I just lose it like I have I have
one sip of whiskey I'm like I want to do
anything other than this right now well
what about a nice hotel versus a seedy
motel because one you kind of think like
you get your brain gets trick that life
is good and safe and the other one you
realize like there's a desperation do
some of it well there between a seedy
motel or a nice motel the only thing the
only thing that's important is that you
go someplace incredibly boring so that
there's nothing tempting you to do
anything else and you know one time I
wanted to work on his scripts so I went
to like the Glendale Hilton hmm in
beautiful Glendale California just
because I knew there was nothing around
there to walk to to that that would be
that would tempt me to like go to
someplace because everything around
there was like offices that closed down
and so I was like oh great and even when
I've gone to Palm Springs I remember one
time I I did I like doing the the
Travelocity secret deal like where you
don't know where you're staying
you just do the price of it because you
can often say someplace cool for like
half the price because you're basically
promising to stay there no matter what
so I remember once I had to go for like
a week to write a script and it was the
fall was like October and so I go and
Travelocity secret deal and they're like
you can stay at a five-star resort in
Palm Springs for like 70 bucks a night
and I was like okay so I did it
but you know the secret deal you have to
agree to pay no matter what they can
tell you you're staying at the fleabag
motel and you have to stay there I mean
it has to at least be the star rating
that you signed up for but anyway so you
because you pay ahead of time you have
to pay before you even know where you're
staying so anyway so I did it and they
put me at the Riviera and Palm Springs
which is like a cool retro like 1960s
resume hotel so I show up and it's
October and I walk in and I was like hey
there we go welcome mr. Berger you're
here for five days I see and I'm like
yeah what's important I'm here to write
like I had my laptop and I'm here to
write for five days so I need to make
sure my room has a desk in it because I
don't want to be stuck in a room that
doesn't have a desk I'm gonna write and
they're like oh well actually our only
rooms with desks are like back in Tower
4 which doesn't have a view of the pool
is actually not by the pool I'm like
that's fine I have no desire to go to
the pool I'm not getting in the pool
like well it's also not near the fitness
center or the bar and like that's fine I
don't want to be near any of the cool
stuff I just want a nice quiet room that
has a desk in it and okay cool well just
so you know you're gonna be the only
person in Tower 4 and I was like perfect
so busy like The Shining for a week
because I was literally the only person
an entire wing of this resort and it was
October in Palm Springs which is like
the windy season so you'd be sitting
there like working and you just hear
like the howling winds outside
like trees smashing up against the
window and you would go walk around
these big spooky totally empty hallways
and it was pretty awesome
and I've tried to replicate it but it's
never worked out it was a magical time
but I highly recommend that going to
Palm Springs in the off season because
it's super cheap because nobody's there
like when it's everyone goes for the
summer I like to go in pools but go to
Palm Springs and like October November
and nobody's there it's great hole up
someplace it's magic
you